- I get the question all the time,
wasn't it wonderful
in 1947 Jackie Robinson
breaks the color barrier?
Opens up Major League
Baseball to everyone.
- My answer has to be no, it wasn't.
It was actually more difficult
for African American ballplayers.
- Many talented black
players got phased out.
- Racism ended my professional career.
- The primary reason
for the end of the Negro
Leagues is integration.
- What we saw with the Negro Leagues
and particularly those Negro League teams
that were in close proximity
to Major League teams they died
in almost instant debt
because that black fan base left
to go see Jackie
to go see Larry Doby.
- We're trying to get to the Major Leagues
and once that was an option,
the segregated teams and leagues
were abandoned completely.
- In the fifties, the
Indianapolis clowns dropped
out of the Negro American league.
- Down all the great players,
they've been signed to Major League.
- Folks that own the teams
and that were very smart individuals,
they knew baseball
but they also knew business.
- Did Paula, Abe Saperstein
who both had business interests
in the Harlem Globetrotters,
hired women to play for
the Indianapolis Clowns.
- Surprising that I seen women
playing in Negro Leagues.
They could play.
- Tony Stone was the first woman
to play for the Indianapolis Clowns.
- She's followed by the
Mamie Peanut Johnson
and Connie Morgan
who competed against the men in the 1950s.
- Was it a promotional gimmick? Yes.
Was it successful? Yes.
- They were trying to get
people to the ballparks.
And at the same time,
they're selling their best players
to the Major Leagues,
trying to fill the role of
all these lost ballplayers.
And it really doesn't work.
And if it did work for some teams,
it only worked maybe four, five years
- Unfortunately,
just because Jackie Robinson
integrated baseball,
that didn't change the fact
that it was gonna be very difficult
for young black ballplayers.
- Before I leave this earth,
somebody out there know the answer,
Why is it at that time
they were drafting black men to go fight
in that foolish country,
but it didn't want us to play baseball
for this country?
Black men have built this country.
- History isn't always necessarily pretty
and it's not always
as glamorous as people
would like it to be.
There were a lot of guys
that never got the opportunity
to go beyond minor league baseball.
- There's no question that that
was a quota system in place
when that first group of
black players transition
into the Major Leagues.
- I had the fortune of knowing a gentleman
by the name of Bobby Bragan.
Bobby was the manager for
the Pittsburgh Pirates
at the time.
He was very honest with me.
He said, "We had a quota
system back in those days."
You couldn't have more
than four black ballplayers
from your team.
End of story.
And that was pushing it.
- I wanted to make it to the Major League.
I thought I was gonna make
it with my speed and hitting
because I could hit.
- 1950s, Jake gets signed
by the Brooklyn Dodgers organization.
They sent him to minor
league training camp.
He has a phenomenal training camp.
The leading hitter on the
team, starting outfielder,
they make the cuts for the season.
Jake's one of the first ones to get cut.
Why do you cut the best
baseball player on your team?
- That's what hurt me so bad.
When they cut me for a white kid,
betting to sick to forward
and I'm betting cleanup.
- I was serious about the game,
but it was one of those things.
- Pedro played everywhere
you can play professional baseball.
He played in the Negro Leagues.
He played in Minor League Baseball.
He played in Canada.
He played in Dominican Republic.
He played in Mexico.
- I don't have any
regrets of what happened.
I thought, I think to myself
that I could have played.
And those who played around me knew
that I could.
- When I got in professional baseball,
I didn't realize just how bad racism was.
- Ernest got to play
in the St. Louis Cardinals organization.
- The next year I was traded
to the Kansas City A's.
That's when racism set in.
My own teammate,
they didn't even want me to
sit on the bench with 'em.
Lot of people in the stand,
I could take that and keep walking,
but my own teammate,
it bothered me
because I felt that
baseball was for everybody.
They figured I'll get discouraged and quit
but I told them I could play
anywhere on the baseball field.
So what they started doing,
they will make up excuses
to make sure no other team sign you.
They said, "You play your music too loud."
Man.
I wouldn't make a lot money
to buy stereo or radio.
- If America truly appreciated
the greatest athletes,
there wouldn't have been a Negro League.
There wouldn't have been
an all white Major League.
And then we would have truly seen
the greatest baseball players of all time.
Those aren't the truly greatest numbers
because they didn't include
the truly greatest players.
- There has been said oh
we don't have the stats,
but I found score books.
I found in some of the black newspapers,
they kept score on a tally.
- Since 1947, think of all the records
that have fallen related
to African American baseball players
that didn't have to start in 1947.
It could've started in 1907.
It could've started in 1887.
So, based by history it would be changed,
but we will never know how much.
- But this story,
the crux of it looks at a story that is
about the importance of
economic empowerment.
It is a story about an
unprecedented level of leadership
that emerged as a result of
the formation of these leagues.
- Black cultures, black
owners, black executives,
they were done once the Negro Leagues died
and we don't hear about them.
What would it mean
if black kids didn't just
wanna be the next Satchel Paige
or Josh Gibson,
but they wanted to be
the next Gus Greenlee
or the next Effa Manley.
- One of the things I
would like to see happen is
that it would be in schools
because the Negro League
accomplish a lot of things
other than just baseball.
The Negro League made
not only black history,
American history
- And all of that is wrapped
around this amazing story
of these very courageous athletes
who as I like to say
forged a glorious history
in the midst of an inglorious
time in American history
to play the game they love.
- We don't want people to
forget about Josh Gibson
and not just Josh Gibson
I'm talking about the Negro Leagues.
So, what we're trying to do
is keep his legacy alive is
through the Josh Gibson foundation.
It's making sure that
the youth is educated
on the Negro Leagues
as well as making sure they
get the right education
to further the education.
So we have a Josh Gibson scholarships.
We have a Josh Gibson curriculum.
It teaches kids the
business side of sports,
sports media, sports law,
sports marketing, sports sales.
- When we built the Negro
League Baseball Museum
30 years ago,
we knew then that it was
literally a race against time.
That those who had created this history,
it wasn't a matter of if.
It was simply a matter of when
we were going to lose them
and that it was so vitally important
that their story and
their legacy would play on
long after there were
no Negro League players
to attest to the greatness
of these leagues.
- A lot of the researchers
are getting older like myself.
You know, I'm 70 years old
and it's tremendously gratifying to me
that there's someone there
to carry on this legacy.
- As we celebrate the 100 year anniversary
of the Negro Leagues,
a Major League Baseball
has many commitment
to also honor Negro Leagues.
Back in August, they all
were to Centennial patch.
There's been several Major
League baseball teams
who recognized Negro
League baseball players.
Milwaukee Brewers
celebrated Negro Leagues.
Pittsburgh Pirates, Atlanta Braves,
Kansas City Royals, Chicago
White Sox, Detroit Tigers
by either bringing some of
these players back to honor them
or just having some kind of exhibit
to showcase their fans.
(upbeat music)
- Right now, I'm trying to
get young kids back interested
in baseball.
I coach little league team.
I talk to kids.
- What the Negro Leagues
teaches us is quite simple.
In this country of ours,
if you dare to dream
and you believe in yourself,
you can do or be anything you want to be.
- And if we were able to accomplish
what we were able to accomplish in 1920
with far less resources,
what are we capable of now?
I think the legacy honestly
is that we are more powerful
than we know.
- They had no idea that
they were making history.
They didn't care about making history.
They just wanted to play ball.
(upbeat music)